here are 10 things
wealthy people who used to be poor
have learned about money and they're
sharing it with you let's go real quick
let's let's it's almost like a top 10
list
people that used to be poor but now
they're wealthy here's what they want to
share with you about money number one
everything costs more when you're poor
buying things in bulk is cheaper but
when you're poor you're not buying
toothpaste multi-pack it's too much up
front all right so this is a principle
we've heard before that's why people go
to costco and get ketchup packets
bottles of ketchup for the year or they
get deodorant for the year toothpaste
for the year
because they're going to you know
need it all year i think mark cuban
always talks about this absolutely yeah
big thing buying bulk
buying bulks that's number one you know
how you know old people they say i don't
even buy green bananas
right right you know if you if you uh
paul i'm looking at you if you need two
packs of deodorant you go ahead and
splurge treat yourself oh yeah all right
that's my guide
um so that's number one everything costs
more on your poor because you're buying
single items rather than
the multi-pack the buying in bulk
number two the difference in quality
between cheap crap
and the middle range is often far larger
than the difference between the middle
range and the very expensive even though
the price gap is about the same or more
all right let me break this down for you
if
um
if you're gonna buy a belt right and you
get three different options the cheap
shitty belt five bucks right
middle range decent belt 50 bucks and
then you got the most expensive belt 500
bucks what they're saying is
split the difference
by the one in the middle because the
cheap one is so janky that it's you're
gonna have to buy a belt you know
next month right and now you're buying a
new freaking belt
and the 500 one is so expensive that
it's not that much better than the 50
belt
so the point is this
split the difference go in the middle
don't you don't have to buy gucci it
doesn't need to be a 500
belt you don't have to go get a louis
vuitton belt shout out to our guy
bernard or no
but you don't need to buy the five
dollar dollar store belt right middle
range middle ring what kind of belt
you're working with um i
i'm wearing
reaction by kenneth cole belt shout out
to kenneth copeland
all right so split the difference don't
buy the cheap one you don't have to buy
the most expensive one you don't have to
buy the name brand belt you just get
something decent that'll do the trick
and literally just keep your pants up
there it is all right number three we
talked about this earlier
a bigger house means bigger
headaches i always ask friends of mine
on a scale of one to ten people that own
homes how much you love being a
homeowner how much you love being a
homeowner and the answers vary sometimes
i'll get eight nines tens and sometimes
i'll get dude freaking it's i hate it
two
i'm never gonna own a house again i'm
just gonna rent
and just keep my expenses low
and move around and be flexible i'm sick
of the maintenance god for you know the
toilet the plumber the
the refrigerator the air cuz there's so
much expenses the taxes
okay it's not that easy so i ask people
this all the time the answers vary
but a bigger house means bigger
headaches you never have a day in your
life where you're like you don't have to
cut the lawn
that there's some issue the toilet
overflowed it's just not fun
you got to be really ready for that you
got to be ready you got to be ready so a
bigger house needs bigger headaches
number four money can't buy happiness
but here's what it can buy it can buy a
sense of financial relief a nice house
a car that won't blow a gasket on the
freeway a vacation abroad a trip to the
grocery store without having to keep
track of the total that's awesome and a
full tank of gas instead of just 20 at a
time and so on so you work hard you make
this money so you don't have to look at
the price tag for everything but if
you're smart you look at the price tag
make sure that you're not spending too
much but anyway money can't buy
happiness but i can buy a lot of other
stuff that's number four number five
this is advice by the way that people
who used to be poor are giving after
being wealthy number five the real
currency is time
the real currency is time real wealth
means having the time to enjoy life
without having to worry about the money
we've heard this a million times we'll
say it again time is money our friend
gerard talks about it's not income it's
hours of your life to earn the income
okay
if you work your ass off you're working
time time it's not necessarily the money
the real currency is time
number six the best thing that money
gives me is freedom to make choices the
best thing that you could say
is i'm good i don't need the job or hey
we're gonna need you to come and uh do
this uh thing for 500 bucks for the
weekend and we're gonna need to do this
now i'm good it gives you the ability to
say no it's a beautiful thing that's
freedom now if you want to do and you
want to make the money say yes obviously
but if you have no money you have to say
yes to everything if you have money
saved up and you're good and you're
chilling someone offers you something
you can say no that's the difference
that's what they're talking about here
with freedom number seven the more money
you have the easier it is to make money
it takes money to make money it's kind
of like you had an analogy that you
wanted to use with it's kind of you were
like listen if you're going after a girl
nobody likes a thirsty dude right right
or anything
in any way yeah like even in uh at work
like you don't want to be like overly
you know
aggressive or like beg you never want to
beg for anything you kind of want to
just ease your way into most things and
then people kind of want you to
you know do more less is more i think
more so when you have more money the
easier it is to make money
right um
something that just to keep you know
keep that in your pocket right there it
takes money to make money and when you
get the money you can invest in things
people always say all the time i wish i
had the the 20 grand to invest in them i
wish i did
well
you could have had it if you played your
cards right all right number eight i
realize inflation keeps taking my goals
further away even though i saved so much
it seems like everything inflates out of
reach just before my life gets there
that's interesting someone who's wealthy
is worried about inflation what did
warren buffett say about inflation they
said the best protection about inflation
has nothing to do with your money per se
it has to do with your skill set be the
best at something remember when warren
buffett said this yeah the guaranteed
way to not get your to worry about
inflation is just be the best at
something
people that are people that are the best
at something will never be where you'll
never have to worry about inflation but
also
i didn't learn about inflation in
in school
you're circling back that's a callback
right i had no idea about inflation in
school so i think that might be a good
thing to teach people is that if you
just put the money in the bank
you could be losing
listen uh nobody's gone broke by having
money in the bank that's a good idea
maybe you lose one two percent five
percent of inflation you don't go broke
that's that's not about okay so you were
too busy we're learning about hades and
greek mythology in school inflation is
the thing it's real on average it's two
percent a year we get it right now it's
a little bit higher than usual maybe
double four five percent
nobody's going broke because of
inflation it is a silent thief that
steals your money as they say that's why
you need to invest because you know just
having all your money sitting there in a
bank account it is losing money over
time but nobody goes poor or broke
because of inflation but you want to
beat inflation you do
number nine
here it is
you can have too much stuff
you can have too much of salary is not
wealth that's temporary money this
person goes on to say diversified income
generating investments are the
foundation
of wealth if i could go back to my 20s
this is rich guy talking right now
number nine
and spend even one tenth less on stupid
crap instead
invest in it i'd be better
off today mo money mo problems is for
people with no control over their
spending it's called a budget it's
called a game plan for your money it's
called understanding your income versus
your expenses and it just seems to be a
common theme here
save your money invest your money don't
spend it on stupid and you're going
to be better off that's some or not and
then
last thing number 10 there's actually of
the people that are that these rich
these rich people that used to be poor
we had a celebrity appearance on this
top 10 list
and it was none other than kanye
kanye had some wise words for the people
he says having money isn't everything
but not having it
is okay having money isn't everything
but if you ain't got none
that's a problem that's gonna be an
issue that's a problem
i got 99 problems but money ain't won
these days that's kanye anyway it's
always worse to be broke okay
anyway
those are the 10 things
that wealthy people learned about money
after
they went from being poor to being
wealthy
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken